[Music]
well people are gonna start to wonder if
our Carly Steele is stalking Vin Diesel
she was on the set of the new xxx movie
in London she joined him for a surprise
screening in Hollywood and now Carly has
followed VIN all the way to Brazil for
their craziest encounter yet have you
been enjoying South Paulo so far how do
you not enjoy it
how did not enjoy it look at my eyes
with how much VIN headline Sao Paulo's
comic-con where he's promoting xxx
return of xander cage
I was in the room when you came out for
the Q&A I mean people were going not
even before you came out it's just a
kind of a fever there's a kind of energy
here that is wonderful it's a life force
it's just so much beautiful talented
strong formidable the women interval X
are the badasses I guess better on the
same team now you ready to have some fun
Vince says making the film was a welcome
distraction making this movie came after
a very difficult time making Furious 7
and so never in my life did I need to do
a movie where I could laugh more than
right now during filming for Furious 7
VIN lost close friend Paul Walker this
week marked the third anniversary of
Paulson fatal car wreck you know the
last three years have been some of the
hardest years of my life because of
losing a brother like that
there was a lot of tissues and it was a
hard morning yesterday
you